a new study out of Japan is saying that
people who stare at screens all day long
laptop screens the specifically falling
screens they are actually changing the
liquid in their eyes this is really
deranged they're changing tear fluid
similar to people who have a disease
known as dry eye let's look at some info
on the study the protein mu C 5 AC one
of my favorite protein secreted by cells
in the upper eyelid makes up part of the
normally occurring mucous layer or tear
film that keeps the eye moist we all
have this that's why you can blink and
it keeps bad dust and things out of your
eyes study participants with the most
screen time had mu C 5 a sea-levels
nearing those of people with diagnosed
dry eye so when I was reading this
literally I had just woke up and do you
guys go to your phones right when you
wake up because I do it it's a bad habit
I've been trying to break it and I
looked at my phone and there are times
especially first thing in the morning I
wake up and my eyes are dry and I'm
literally I got one eye and I lower the
light on yes and I'm going like this
like what is that so this is happening
this is real what do you think about how
do you keep your eyes moist well I know
the first thing I thought if there's
gonna be so many people that are going
this is stupid this is BS it's not true
shut up but those are people who don't
want to accept that the things that
they're doing are bad for them yeah so
it's I think it's it's probably true I'm
willing to go for it and maybe put my
phone down for another half hour before
I wake up do you have that do you do you
have any moments where you realize that
your eyes are bothering you because of
the screen or the new thing now is
everyone's making their screens darker
at night there's some actually
but another thing we know this is real
because wasn't there a guy in China
recently that detached his retinas he
was texting all night with his
girlfriend literally yes our heads are
gonna pop off next
I mean seriously like this is insane
we're roading our tear ducts where our
eyeballs are popping out of our skulls I
mean maybe we put the phone down for
five minutes yeah I mean are you doing
this are you walking around with your
following because they're saying also
neck things I walked into two glass like
literally just texting away and bam just
done it but when I read this I it sounds
a little insensitive but I'm like dry I
like diagnose dry there's so many other
things that are so much worse than live
like you're gonna hate the dry out a
community which they're a big big deal
and so I just I kind of laughed I was
like it felt like a dust study like of
course if you're staring at a computer
screen or your telephone or anything in
excess is gonna be bad for you I just
don't care that much about dry eyes yes
the girl with Elfi eyes right now who's
walking into glad wait till the day your
walk right to do glass thing and your
phone goes right in your eye okay is
there anything we can do to fight this
stuff because we cuz we all do it we all
do it there is no doubt you know you
mean and I I said it about the wake up
thing I've been trying to shut down I
tried to by 9 o'clock now I've really
been trying I'm not always successful to
stop looking at Twitter so I'm doing you
know my little I'm all you know I barely
open I'm doing Instagram every third day
now instead of every day like I'm just
trying to to slowly do it but do you try
to fight it in any way I'm just ever
encroaching but I'm like I'm gonna speak
for Vanessa when she's gonna be like
Visine and stop crying I think this is
really good information and they're not
even saying like oh god everybody panic
they're like just so you know so you
don't care Doc's are being totally
ravaged but Duke do you yeah what about
you are you doing anything to fight it
or because you admit it you freely admit
it yeah I I'm more so the type person is
like okay when I'm at home it's family
time let's put away our phones it's
dinner time let's put away our phones
but not because I'm scared of dry ice
well connect with real people I don't
want to always be you
doing it for the likes I just want to
like get back to dinnertime where you
talk to your family yeah look what you
say dry eye can you say that he's right
such a venom dry